i admire longevity in this business and
in a way you got to find your niche
that's the thing you got to find what
sells to your audience the dna
became the signature show yeah you guys
had no idea it wasn't like you set out
to do a dna show no but when you sit and
break the news to some guy
that whether he is the father isn't the
father you can go back to that well over
and over and over again it's also the
women because sometimes they're naming
these guys oh and by the way they never
are the father the biggest reaction is
is when they're not the father yeah
right and i did one smart thing
unknowingly in the beginning in the
first dna show when the
producer is briefing you about the story
and you've read all about the story and
then they say and the result is and i
said you know
i don't want to know the result i don't
want to know anything the guest doesn't
know
the live audience doesn't know the
viewers at home i don't want to know any
because i'd skew the questions because i
knew something more you want to find out
at the same time when i open up that
envelope
i'm with everybody else wow do you think
if the original way the show had been
pitched to you if they said maury we
want the mori show to be a dna show i'd
say you got the wrong guy yeah
what what happens is you get into the
heat of the battle and the maury show
used to be more oprah
very much so so what happened one day
you do a dna test and do the ratings
spike up do you watch that maybe not the
first but maybe the second or third you
know pretty quickly
i mean i know today if i do
like in sweeps
if i do dna
lie detector tests out of control
teenagers that's for the entire month
i'm not going on uh uh is she a man or a
woman beauty contest i'm not going on
phobias uh people who are scared of
pickles and cotton balls i'm not doing
that right but
in sweeps period those three themes hit
the mark do you worry that some shows
would copy that formula they tried they
tried there was one that was all dna
it's the same thing as you all people
try to copy you
it doesn't work so what is it do you
think it's your presence you have a
certain credibility with the audience i
think that's
and and howard i'll tell you i don't
know why that is but somehow there's a
connection you know what i think it is
you look the part of the credible
anchorman you look
conservative uh and you know you come on
and you have a certain demeanor and that
helps too because it gives the show a
certain credibility i think that i am
god well not god but but i'm the uh
maybe older uncle something that uh i ha
i know more about the world maybe than
they do and they can unburden themselves
and and
start again when you deliver dna results
do they have heavy security there are
you afraid that somebody will kill
somebody over it or get so angry and
violent well they you know there's a lot
of dumping on chairs right uh guys when
they're proved not to be the father they
do backflips right on do some of them
put that on just because they know
they're on tv no no it's a very genuine
reaction yeah yeah and and and you think
it's pretty serious yeah am i the father
i'm not the father and these women go
nuts too because they run back i did a
tyler perry movie one time with medea
you know when he plays medea
and she is using the theme
and they had me in the studio and he
knew every move
that all of the women make when they're
when they're when it's not the father
and she runs off the stage buries
herself in the sofa puts the pillow over
her head and starts kicking their heels
at this point having done it so many
years are you a bit tired of it are you
is it like kind of the job that you like
you keep hitting it with the stick but
it won't go away every story is unique
in some way and you like it i love it